welcome to the introduction to the
generative AI Studio course in this
video you learn what generative AI
studio is and describe its options for
use you also demo the generative AI
Studios language tool yourself what is
generative AI
it is a type of artificial intelligence
that generates content for you
what kind of content well the generative
content can be multimodal including text
images audio and video when given a
prompt or a request generative AI can
help you achieve various tasks such as
document summarization information
extraction code generation marketing
campaign creation virtual assistance and
call center bot and these are just a few
examples how does AI generate new
content it learns from a massive amount
of existing content this includes text
audio and video the process of learning
from existing content is called training
which results in the creation of a
foundation model in llm or large
language model which Powers chat Bots
like Bard is a typical example of a
foundation model the foundation model
can then be used to generate content and
solve General problems such as content
extraction and document summarization it
can also be trained further with new
data sets in your field to solve
specific problems such as financial
model generation and Healthcare
Consulting this results in the creation
of a new model that is tailored to your
specific needs
how can you use the foundation model to
power your applications and how can you
further train or tune the foundation
model to solve a problem in your
specific field Google Cloud provides
several easy to use tools that help you
use generative AI in your projects with
or without an AI and machine learning
background
one such tool is vertex AI
vertex AI is an end-to-end ml
development platform on Google Cloud
that helps you build deploy and manage
machine learning models with vertex AI
if you are an app developer or data
scientist and want to build an
application you can use generative AI
Studio to quickly prototype and
customize generative AI models with no
code or low code if you are a data
scientist or ml developer who wants to
build and automate a generative AI model
you can start from model Garden
model Garden lets you discover and
interact with Google's foundation and
third-party open source models and has
built-in ml Ops tools to automate the ml
pipeline
in this course you focus on generative
AI Studio
generative AI Studio supports language
vision and speech the list grows as you
are learning this course
for language you can design a prompt to
perform tasks in tune language models
for vision you can generate an image
based on a prompt and further edit the
image for speech you can generate text
from speech or vice versa
let's focus on what you can do with
language and generative AI Studio
specifically you can design prompts for
tasks relevant to your business use case
including code generation
create conversations by specifying the
context that instructs how the model
should respond and tune a model so it is
better equipped for your use case which
allows you to then deploy to an endpoint
to get predictions or tested in prompt
design let's walk through these three
features in detail first is prompt
design to get started experimenting with
large language models or llms click on
new prompt
in the world of generative AI a prompt
is just a fancy name for the input text
that you feed to your model you can feed
your desired input text like questions
and instructions to the model the model
will then provide a response based on
how you structured your prompt therefore
the answers you get depend on the
questions you ask the process of
figuring out and designing the best
input text to get the desired response
back from the model is called prompt
design which often involves a lot of
experimentation let's start with a free
form prompt one way to design a prompt
is to Simply tell the model what you
want in other words provide an
instruction for example generate a list
of items I need for a camping trip to
Joshua Tree National Park we send this
text to the model and you can see the
model outputs a useful list of items we
don't want to camp without
this approach of writing a single
command so that the llm can adopt a
certain behavior is called zero shot
prompting generally there are three
methods that you can use to shape the
model's response in a way that you
desire zero shot prompting is a method
where the llm is given no additional
data on the specific task that is being
asked to perform instead it is only
given a prompt that describes the task
for example if you want the llm to
answer a question you just prompt what
is prompt design One-Shot prompting is a
method where the llm is given a single
example of the task that is being asked
to perform for example if you want the
llm to write a poem you might provide a
single example poem and few shot
prompting is a method where the llm is
given a small number of examples of the
task that it is being asked to perform
for example if you want the llm to write
a news article you might give it a few
news articles to read you can use the
structured mode to design the fuse shot
prompting by providing a context and
examples for the model to learn from
the structured prompt contains a few
different components first we have the
context which instructs how the model
should respond you can specify words the
model can or cannot use topics to focus
on are avoid or a particular response
format and the context applies each time
you send a request to the model let's
say we want to use an llm to answer
questions based on some background text
in this case a passage that describes
changes in rainforest vegetation in the
Amazon we can paste in the background
text as the context
then we add some examples of questions
that could be answered from this passage
like what does lgm stand for or what did
the analysis from the sentiment deposits
indicate we'll need to add in the
corresponding answers to these questions
to demonstrate how we want the model to
respond then we can test out the prompt
we've designed by sending a new question
as input and there you go you've
prototyped a q a system based on
background text in just a few minutes
please note a few best practices around
prompt design be concise be specific and
well-defined ask one task at a time turn
generative tasks into classification
tasks for example instead of asking what
programming language to learn ask if
python Java or C is a better fit for a
beginner in programming an improve
response quality by including examples
adding instructions in a few examples
tends to yield good results however
there's no one best way to write a
prompt you may need to experiment with
different structures formats and
examples to see what works best for your
use case for more information about
prompt design please check text prompt
design in the reading list
so if you've designed a prompt that you
think is working pretty well you can
save it and return to it later your
saved prompt will be visible in the
prompt Gallery which is a curated
collection of sample prompts that show
how generative AI models can work for a
variety of use cases finally in addition
to testing different prompts and prompt
structures there are a few model
parameters you can experiment with to
try and improve the quality of responses
first there are different models you can
choose from each model is tuned to
perform well on specific tasks you can
also specify the temperature top p and
top k
these parameters all adjust the
randomness of responses by controlling
how the output tokens are selected when
you send a prompt to the model it
produces an array of probabilities over
the words that could come next and from
this array we need some strategy to
decide what to return
a simple strategy might be to select the
most likely word at every time step but
this method can result in uninteresting
and sometimes repetitive answers on the
contrary if you randomly sample over the
distribution returned by the model you
might get some unlikely responses by
controlling the degree of Randomness you
can get more unexpected and some might
say creative responses back to the model
parameters temperature is a number used
to tune the degree of Randomness low
temperature means to select the words
that are highly possible and more
predictable in this case those are
flowers and the other words that are
located at the beginning of the list
this setting is generally better for
tasks like q a and summarization where
you expect a more predictable answer
with less variation high temperature
means to select the words that have low
possibility and are more unusual in this
case those are bugs and the other words
that are located at the end of the list
this setting is good if you want to
generate more creative or unexpected
content in addition to adjusting the
temp aperture top K lets the model
randomly return a word from the top K
number of words in terms of possibility
for example top 2 means you get a random
word from the top two possible words
including flowers and trees this
approach allows the other high scoring
word a chance of being selected however
if the probability distribution of the
words is highly skewed and you have one
word that is very likely and everything
else is very unlikely this approach can
result in some strange responses
the difficulty of selecting the best top
K value leads to another popular
approach that dynamically sets the size
of the short list of words
top P allows the model to randomly
return a word from the top P probability
of words
with top P you choose from a set of
words with the sum of the likelihoods
not exceeding P for example P of 0.75
means you sample from a set of words
that have accumulative probability
greater than 0.75 in this case it
includes three words flowers trees and
herbs
this way the size of the set of words
can dynamically increase and decrease
according to the probability
distribution of the next word in the
list
in some generative AI Studio provides a
few model parameters for you to play
with such as the model temperature top K
and top P note that you are not required
to adjust them constantly especially top
K and top p
now let's look at the second feature
which creates conversations
first you need to specify the
conversation context context instructs
how the model should respond
for example specifying words the model
can or cannot use topics to focus on or
avoid or response format context applies
each time you send a request to the
model
for a simple example you can define a
scenario and tell the AI how to respond
to help desk queries your name is Roy
you are a support technician of an I.T
Department you only respond with have
you tried turning it off and on again to
any queries you can tune the parameters
on the right the same as you do when
designing the prompt
to see how it works you can type my
computer is slow in the chat box and
press enter the AI responds have you
tried turning it off and on again
exactly as you told the AI to do
the cool thing is that Google provides
the apis and sdks to help you build your
own application you can simply click
view code first you need to download the
vertex AI sdks that fit your programming
language like Python and curl SDK stands
for software design kits they implement
the functions and do the job for you you
use them like you call libraries from
the code you then follow the sample code
and the API and insert the code into
your application
now let's look at the third feature tune
a language model if you've been
prototyping with large language models
you might be wondering if there's a way
you can improve the quality of responses
Beyond just prompt design so let's learn
how to tune a large language model and
how to launch a tuning job from
generative AI Studio as a quick recap
The Prompt is your text input that you
pass to the model your prompt might look
like an instruction and maybe you add
some examples then you send this text to
the model so that it adopts the behavior
that you want
prompt design allows for fast
experimentation and customization and
because you're not writing any
complicated code you don't need to be an
ml expert to get started
but producing prompts can be tricky
small changes in wording or word order
can affect the model results in ways
that aren't totally predictable and you
can't really fit all that many examples
into a prompt even when you do discover
a good prompt for your use case you
might notice the quality of model
responses isn't totally consistent one
thing we can do to alleviate these
issues is to tune the model so what's
tuning well one version you might be
familiar with is fine tuning in this
scenario we take a model that was
pre-trained on a generic data set we
make a copy of this model then using
those learned weights as a starting
point we retrain the model on a new
domain-specific data set this technique
has been pretty effective for lots of
different use cases but when we try to
fine-tune llms we run into some
challenges llms are well as the name
suggests large so updating every weight
can take a long training job compound
all of that computation with the hassle
and cost of now having to serve this
giant model and as a result fine-tune a
large language model might not be the
best option for you but there is an
Innovative approach to tuning called
parameter efficient tuning this is a
super exciting research area that aims
to reduce the challenges of fine-tuning
llms by only training a subset of
parameters these parameters might be a
subset of the existing model parameters
or they could be an entirely new set of
parameters for example maybe you add on
some additional layers to the model or
an extra embedding to The Prompt if you
want to learn more about parameter
efficient tuning and some of the
different methods a summary paper is
included in the reading list of this
course but if you just want to get to
building then let's move to generative
AI studio and see how to start a tuning
job from the language section of
generative AI Studio select tuning to
create a tune model we provide a name
then point to the local or cloud storage
location of your training data parameter
efficient tuning is ideally suited for
scenarios where you have modest amounts
of training data say hundreds or maybe
thousands of training examples
your training data should be structured
as a supervised training data set in a
text to text format each record or Row
in the data will contain the input text
in other words The Prompt which is
followed by the expected output of the
model this means that the model can be
tuned for a task that can be modeled as
a text to text problem
after specifying the path to your data
set you can start the tuning job and
monitor the status in the Google Cloud
console when the tuning job completes
you'll see the tuned model in the vertex
AI model registry and you can deploy it
to an endpoint for serving or you can
test it in the generative AI Studio
in this course you learned what
generative AI is and the tools provided
by Google Cloud to empower your project
with generative AI capabilities
specifically you focused on generative
AI Studio where you can use gen AI in
your application by quickly prototyping
and customizing generative AI models you
learn that generative AI Studio supports
three options language vision and speech
you then walked through the three major
features in language design and test
prompt create conversations and tune
models
this was a short lesson introducing
generative AI Studio on vertex AI for
more information about natural language
processing and different types of
language models like decoder encoder
Transformer and llm please check the
course titled natural language
processing on Google Cloud listed in the
reading list
now it's time to play with generative AI
studio in a Hands-On lab where you
design and test prompts in both free
form and structured modes create
conversations and explore the prompt
Gallery by the end of this lab you will
be able to use the capabilities of
generative AI Studio that we've
discussed in this course have fun
exploring